i've got a great a little lesson for all
of you today in uh historical
revisionism and gaslighting put together
you might be familiar with kaylee
mcinanny she's donald trump's latest
press secretary
she has done a few press briefings lying
regularly for donald trump she says that
trump is the best president ever
she justifies anything he does and says
she's the epitome of a true brown-nosing
sycophant
but she was not always like this as far
as
trump is concerned because back during
the 2016 republican primary
she said trump is hateful and says
racist things we have the video let's
take a look at it
how sick of polls are people in new
hampshire right now probably very sick
especially when they see that donald
trump is number two
and doesn't deserve to be there the gop
doesn't need to be turning away voters
and isolating them we need to be
bringing them into the tent
donald trump is the last person who's
going to do that kaylee this is your guy
he's number two in the polls
hey i don't want to claim this guy the
fact that the republican party is now
having to claim him
is both unfortunate and to me
inauthentic what's the expiration date
then on a racist statement to me a
racist statement's a racist statement i
don't like what donald trump said i
don't like what al sharpton says and at
what point does it expire and becomes
something
trump is racist trump is hateful she
doesn't like it she doesn't like him
now here's the real payoff kaylee was
asked about these past statements by
reporter yamiche
alcindor during a recent press briefing
and her
answer is the epitome of an orwellian
look the other way sort of answer she
says
you know i mistakenly thought trump was
racist
because i was reading cnn headlines
at the time this is her explanation take
a look at it
question i have is in 2015 shortly after
the president said
that some mexican immigrants were
rapists and criminals you said that that
language was racist
and hateful do you still believe that
today well i'm actually glad you asked
that because
for about the first four weeks of the
election
um i was watching cnn and i was naively
believing some of the headlines that i
saw
on cnn and headlines that's fine i just
want to know if you also personally
still
i'm actually not going to read the
headlines so i very quickly
came around supported the president in
fact cnn hired me um i was
on many eight on one panels where i
proudly supported this president who i
believe
is one of the best presidents if not the
best president this country will ever
have
but i i would encourage the individual
who did that analysis of my past
rather than focusing on me he really
should be focused on some of the very
guests cnn chose to have
on their network he should be focused on
i mean my over here jim
jim clapper who said you know 10 days
before he privately told investigators
there was no evidence of collusion
okay so her notes for this question
include
attacks on cnn guests and we can stop it
right there
her argument is when i said what i said
about donald trump when i said he was a
hateful racist and
all that stuff i was wrong because i
fell for cnn headlines i no longer
fall for cnn headlines like i did back
then
how easy to trick her though right can
she really be trusted if she so easily
fell
for supposedly fake headlines from cnn
and do we trust her judgment
if she took a job with cnn as she says
despite believing that they are fake
news
now i really need you to understand
something trumpists
see that and they think it makes sense
trumpists are
thrilled with kaylee mcinanny they're
gleefully cheering how she's been
owning the media with these huge alpha
takedowns of the biased fake news press
corps
it is literal nonsense which only calls
into question her own
judgment if she fell for supposedly fake
headlines
and the trumpists love it they regularly
tweet about how kaylee mcinanni is just
crushing these reporters during press
briefings
now on principle this explanation is
absurd
but of course it's not just about
headlines
she came up with these opinions on her
own it's not that she was repeating
like i know you all know that it's a
dumb explanation
but she was coming up with stuff on her
own that was anti-trump i'll give you an
example on august 6th of 2015 she
tweeted
everyone seems to have a plan except
trump live
during a republican primary debate she
didn't get that from cnn
that's her opinion she came up with that
she volunteered it
so do i think for a second that kaylee
mcinanni
truly believes trump is the best
president in history
i don't believe it for a second do i
think she's willing to say
anything at any time in order to justify
her own career
and try to advance her own interests
which right now includes impressing
donald trump and having
this national platform of press
briefings of course and
every time she tweets every time she
speaks to the press that's exactly what
she's doing
and then maybe most importantly is it
working
and the answer is on trumpists it is
trumpists are
hugely impressed with her every time she
does one of these joke
press briefings don jr retweets it
and talks about it a whole bunch of
people even people that
are only sort of tangentially involved
in politics that i know
who are i'm friends with on facebook and
are sort of centrist
right have been posting clips of kaylee
mcinanny and how great and amazing
everything she's doing is
it's concerning it's extremely
concerning because
she seems to be convincing the exact
people
that needed to feel like here's someone
who can actually hold their own
given that trump can't during these
press briefings and kaylee mcinanni is
doing it for them
again the world is laughing we on the
left
think it's absolutely crazy what she's
doing
but the people she's trying to impress
seem impressed very much so
one of our sponsors nordvpn is giving
you
70 off a three-year plan which comes out
to just a little over three bucks a
month
and you'll get an extra month free when
you go to nordvpn.com
david pakman or just go to their site
and use the coupon code
david pakman it's 2020. there is really
no reason
not to be using a vpn not using a vpn
means
you are not taking your internet safety
seriously i
use nordvpn almost any time i'm using
the internet
it hides your ip address when you're
browsing online keeps you safe from
hackers
keeps websites from tracking your
browsing activity
many advantages and nordvpn is the most
trusted
vpn in the game they don't log your
internet activity
like many other vpns do their servers
are super fast and you can even use it
on your phone
nordvpn is giving you seventy percent
off a three-year plan that's just over
three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
nordvpn.com
david pakman i've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code
david pakman